4. An -ing Phrase.
You can start a sentence with an action ending in -ing.
Looking at the clock, she realized she was going to be late.
Sitting on the beach, I watched the sun set over the ocean.
Running home quickly, she got soaked in the pouring rain.
Or you can use a doing word ending with -ed.
Frightened by the loud fireworks, the dog hid under the table.
Excited about her birthday, she woke up very early.
If you do start with -ing or -ed words,...
...don't forget to use a comma before you complete the sentence.
6. -ly Words.
Finally, the last way to start a sentence is using an -ly word.
Carefully, she tiptoed past the sleeping monster.
Hungrily, the dog chewed the bone.
These -ly words also need a comma before you write the rest of the sentence.
Well, now you know 6 different ways to start a sentence.
Before you start writing, add them to your plan to remind you to use them...
...and you'll find that writing isn't so scary after all.